io sono giuseppe craparo sono uno
psicanalista sono anche docente di
psicologia clinica e riprendono alcune
tematiche che sono state affrontate
lungo tutta la giornata chiaramente il
la prospettiva che oggi vi propongo è
quella una prospettiva che guarda
all'interno diciamo è la prospettiva che
fa riferimento al ruolo delle emozioni
di yacht
devo dire che ho ho la possibilità mi
sento un privilegiato perché oltre a
vedere pazienti non fino fino all'altro
giorno
ascoltando una relazione si parlava di
normalità proprio due giorni fa un mio
paziente mi dice dottore c'è una cosa
difficilissima per me è il quale la cosa
difficilissima essere normali e
complicato come si fa a essere normali
ecco la psicoanalisi è quello che io
opero all'interno della psicoanalisi
come clinico ma anche come ricercatore
questa è anche la mia
la mia fortuna perché ho la possibilità
anche di studiare di di riflettere su
quello che che avviene nella psiche
umana sia a livello individuale che a
livello sociale
bene la psicoanalisi e anche
l'intervento del libro parodi sono
finalizzati su un aspetto secondo me
importante in cui si concentrano e si
incontrano due elementi che di primo
acchito sembrano distanti
uno è quello della psicologia e l'altro
è quella della politica non lo sentiamo
oggi parlare di politica e quasi come
dire un anatema
in realtà io faccio politica se ci
pensiamo chi segue fa un proprio lavoro
con passione con desiderio fa politica a
patto che diamo alla politica un valore
è il suo precipuo che diciamo ci
richiama alla memoria anche la
tradizione e socratica platonica ma
anche preso preso cratica perché dico
questo bene perché il focus del mio
intervento è centrato proprio sulle
emozioni perché l'elemento che
caratterizza la nostra vita nel momento
in cui incontriamo una donna un uomo
perché ci ci approcciamo a quella donna
quell'uomo perché facciamo delle scelte
non solo nell'ambito delle relazioni
interpersonali
mia stessa emozione che provo
nell'essere per la prima volta qui sul
palco no io sono abituato a parlare agli
alunni chiaramente i ritmi sono
completamente differenti abbiamo la
possibilità di riflettere assieme
devo dire che forse l'elemento in comune
che ci rispetta oggi è la qualità il
valore che io do alle elezioni le
elezioni non le considero semplicemente
come colui che sa che si rivolge che
riversa le proprie nozioni proprio
sapere
a qualcuno che diciamo si pone in un
atteggiamento di assoluta passività noda
funzionali anche di questo incontro è
una funzione simile al e vorrei che ci
fosse non la possibilità di seminari e
l'uso di un solco e lasciare magari
qualche cosa che possa in ognuno di noi
sollecitare anche riflessioni pensieri
su di sé e sul mondo allora sono
emozionato non lo nascondo ma che cosa
sono le emozioni che cosa sono le
emozioni in ambito psicoanalitico e
psicologico tukur noi facciamo una
distinzione che fanno anche gli inglesi
nella lingua anglosassone si distingue
in motion nel feeling sono due cose
fondamentali
una distinzione molto importante
soprattutto nell'ambito clinico io vedo
pazienti di tutti i tipi vedo ho a che
fare con manager di successo con
avvocati di successo che un certo punto
arrivano da me mi dico io ho tutto dalla
vita ma non so che cosa voglio non so
chi sono io
guardate che diciamo e paradossalmente
oggi si sono invertiti alcune dinamiche
cioè ho a che fare con adolescenti
annoiati con adulti che non sanno chi
sono
è una situazione un po un po paradossale
però è una situazione che non ci aiuta
ci induce a riflettere chi sono io cosa
voglio ecco l'elemento chiave che ci
propongono in nel lavoro al clinico che
mi propongono nel lavoro clinico in un
interrogativo e sapete qual è la mia
risposta non ho risposte questo è il
punto secondo me di forza meno questo è
l'abito che io trovo più come dire mi
sento più adeguato addosso lo sento più
parte della mia personalità ecco
non si danno risposte proprio quella la
tendenza che noi abbiamo quando parliamo
di società liquida noda società delle
connessioni una società in cui ognuno ci
dà delle risposte so io quello che è
giusto per te so io quello che tu
dovresti fare a questo riguardo mi viene
in mente una pubblicità non ho molto
simpatica non saprei dirvi vado a
memoria di una madre con un bambino un
neonato un infante che parla un'altra
madre non ha questa madre prospetta il
futuro di questo bambino
so quello che fai anzi no andrà nelle
migliori scuole a 18 anni sarà si
iscriverà all'università e
all'università diventerà un avvocato
dopo il che si sposerà insomma il
bambino ha un rigurgito
per fortuna nel senso che si ribella a
un canovaccio già prescritto allora lì
si insedia quella che è la nostra
vocazione politica la vocazione politica
del nostro lavoro a che fare con le
emozioni e a che fare con quella con
quello sviluppo che permettono ognuno di
noi di passare dalle emozioni che come
vedremo prevede delle che ha delle
caratteristiche specifiche a quella che
è un ulteriore capacità e devo dire che
queste una capacità dell'uomo
dell'essere umano quello dei sentimenti
cioè mentre la prima un'esperienza
emozione ex 9 che noi possiamo esprimere
all'esterno che l'altro che l'altro può
cogliere in maniera immediata e visibile
a colpo d'occhio ad occhio nudo il
sentimento un po più complicato cioè un
esperienza privata è un'esperienza e qui
mi rifaccio alla forza dal mio punto di
vista del lavoro psicanalitico è
un'esperienza che si declina al
singolare
ecco questo è un aspetto anche molto
importante
vedete non c'è la questione almeno
nell'ambito psicologiche psicanalitico
la questione del limite
penso che la capacità di saper cogliere
limita importante ma a patto che il
limite
beh significhi qualcosa
soggetto cioè la possibilità di poter
mettere in gioco la propria singolarità
la propria singolarità
cos'è che vuoi non posso dirti io quello
che vuoi tu devi essere tu a dirmelo
devi essere tu ad avere le capacità
quella forza anche psicologica che ti
permetta di poter esplorare il tuo mondo
interno il tuo mondo esterno e di
sintetizzare questa esplorazione in una
parola magica che quella di desiderio
qual è il tuo desiderio allora il lavoro
quando noi lavoriamo come psicologie
psicologi clinici come psicoanalisti non
quando lavoriamo con le emozioni non è
quello di dare a delle risposte ma
aiutare il paziente la persona a passare
da una domanda ad un'altra è quello
l'elemento chiave perché in fondo è la
domanda che ci permette di poter
realizzare questo passaggio dalle
emozioni e sentimenti e la domanda che
ci permette di poter sviluppare in
maniera adeguata la nostra identità e
qual è la prima domanda qual è la prima
domanda pensiamoci
qual è la piena domanda che da piccoli
appena nati
qualcuno ci ha posto è il che vuoi che
vuoi quando il bambino piangere
no è vero che il suo corpo sta chiedendo
un nutrimento un soddisfacimento no
biologico organico corporeo ma quello
che caratterizza il genitore quantomeno
un genitore sufficientemente preoccupato
è quello di cogliere in quel neonato una
singolarità una unicità e perché ci
possa essere questo è necessario e si
crei un sacco una divisione una
separazione non che permetta di
distinguere ciò che sono io e ciò che io
voglio da quello che sei tu da quello
che tu vuoi allora il momento magico e
quello della madre o del padre che dice
rivolgendosi a bambino quando sta anche
quando viaggio anche nel momento in cui
sta per essere allattato dice ah ma
ma che vuoi ecco quello è un momento in
cui viene colto nella sua unicità allora
guardate che quello è un momento
fortemente politico quel momento
realmente politico se noi consideriamo
la politica come la capacità di no di
porci una relazione io tu in cui l'altro
viene colto nella sua unicità come non
me
nel momento in cui io riesco a
rapportarmi con l'altro ea creare uno
spazio che fondamentalmente un grande
psicoanalista parlava di spazio
potenziale cioè uno spazio di gioco e
molti oggi non sanno giocare si prendono
troppo sul serio
io quando si sono un docente
universitario ma nel rapporto con con la
mia famiglia sono giuseppe con gli amici
sono giuseppe non ho la mia card che ho
scritto approccio e giuseppe craparo
cioè la questione è proprio questo che
ha in uno spazio che uno spazio terzo
uno spazio che è nello sviluppo
dell'individuo è legato al reciproco
riconoscimento allora quando c'è il
reciproco riconoscimento al bambino si
dà un'opportunità politica cioè di
vivere la vita in maniera creativa di
vivere la vita sapendo giocare il gioco
è una funzione fondamentale molti di noi
non sanno giocare molti miei pazienti
non hanno se non interno hanno avuto
difficoltà a creare a vivere quello
spazio quello spazio che una volta
interiorizzato è uno spazio fertile da
cui può nascere la loro unicità da cui
può nascere la loro singolarità da cui
può nascere la possibilità di tradurre
appunto le emozioni cioè questa
esperienza emotiva che si traduce in
azioni in comportamenti non verbali in
un qualche cosa di unico che a che fare
ecco come un'altra parola che per me è
una parola chiave vedete noi siamo
anche nel video precedente l'idea è
quella di un dualismo mente corpo la
psicologia in realtà
per questo noi dovremmo anche
richiamarci anche all'etimologia del
termine aggiunge un terzo elemento il
terzo lamento è quello della psiche
della psiche per cui un mio paziente e
de rose che per la mente di ognuno di
noi due più due fa quattro
perché un apprendimento che noi abbiamo
no diciamo e ciò che abbiamo appreso
durante la nostra formazione scolastica
ma un mio paziente un certo punto mi
dice guardi dottori che per me due più
due non ho mai fatto quattro due più due
fa 3 per me
ecco lì si no si inserisce l'unicità
della psiche della psiche cioè un
qualche cosa che non può essere
generalizzato ma in qualche cosa che
deve essere single ha utilizzato allora
quand'è che avviene questo il nucleo
della nostra formazione politica diciamo
così e avviene in questa fase in questa
fase di cui proprio in questa fase
in questa sincronia di sguardi di
movimenti no in questa sincronia di
anche di suoni che danno l'idea del no
di un riconoscimento reciproco in cui il
bambino alla possibilità di riconoscere
chi è se stesso e questo è un momento
fondamentale proprio in senso politico
perché direi che lì si fa omon
d'identità non tanto sociale ma un
identità proprio politica cioè si crea
la capacità del soggetto oltre che di
cogliersi come separato da dall'altro ma
di cogliersi come un soggetto autonomo
non indipendente
l'indipendenza è come dire l'illusione
che alcuni mercati ci ci vogliono
vendere
l'idea di essere totalmente liberi
la libertà non è legata all indipendenza
il rischio è di rimanere in quella
stella di cui ci parla di un relatore
quella è il vero rischio dell'assoluta
indipendenza oltremodo non esiste poi
anche questa questa dimensione la esiste
invece l'autonomia l'autonomia si
l'autonomia ma è il prodotto di uno
sviluppo e la radice di questo prodotto
è legato non solo a queste relazioni
primarie non alle relazioni che noi
chiamiamo chiamiamo di è un attaccamento
sicuro ma sicuramente parte da lì e si
inserisce all'interno di un sistema
sociale socio politico che dovrebbe
favorire questa possibilità no la
possibilità di un riconoscimento
allora quando avviene questo si forma un
identità un'identità autonoma che
esprime la propria libertà
in che modo attraverso il vincolo
io sono libero nel momento in cui mi
sento vincolato con l'altro sento un
vincolo nel momento in cui mi sento
vincolato all'altro esprimono faccio
esperienza anche della responsabilità io
non potrei fare il mio mestiere se non
mi sentissi responsabile di ciò che no
del mio lavoro nel rapporto con il
paziente e questa l'etica questo aspetto
dell'autonomia si lega un altro elemento
che appunto quello del desiderio
allora quello che vuoi ciò che vuoi e
nessuno può dirlo un esempio che io
faccio è quello del fumo capita che fumo
i sigari cubani una quello che noi
dobbiamo che viene molto e difficile
capite sentirsi autonomi e sentirsi e
pensare che la libertà passi dal vincolo
con l'altro allora per questo che cosa
significa significa rinunciare un
pezzetto del proprio narcisismo allora è
l'esempio che io faccio solitamente i
miei studenti è quello di fumare un
cubano per tu hai due modi di
rapportarsi al cubano o lo lasci
dicendolo fumerò un domani il cubano chi
fuma sigari sa che nel tempo sente non
la foglia comunque va incontro al tempo
c'è un'altra possibilità che è in realtà
ogni possibilità fuma mantenere intero
il sigaro
non è possibile l'unico modo per
gustarsi un sigaro e accettare che
sigaro vada incontra la sua fine ma
gustarsi ovviamente quello di tagliare
un pezzettino rinunciare a quel
pezzettino allora la nostra vita
politica è una vita che avviene nel
momento in cui riusciamo a rinunciare a
un pezzettino della scuola a questo
compito fondamentale l'educazione della
scuola e aiutare il ragazzino a
rinunciare a quel pezzettino di
narcisismo che quello che vorrebbe
altrimenti no che cade facilmente
nell'illusione di chi non lo intrappola
nel bisogno di essere ammirato questo
megan delusione che non permette la
crescita
allora la funzione della scuola la
funzione politica è proprio questo
aiutare il bambino a riconoscere se
stesso aiutarlo a riconoscere la propria
singolarità aiutarlo a sentirsi libero
nel vincolo con l'altro
quando questo non avviene chiaramente ci
sono le patologie a livello individuale
ma anche le patologie di sistema le
patologie di sistema che riguardano un
rapporto con l'altro in cui non viene
visto come una fonte di ricchezza nelle
patologie di sistema all'altro viene
visto in due modi sostanzialmente o come
persecutore come nei casi di razzismo o
viene da umanizzato quindi trattato come
un oggetto allora lo sviluppo di un sé
politico e uno sviluppo che nasce dal
rispetto dell'altro inteso come cosa
inteso come ambiente inteso come persona
e come avviene tutto questo come
possiamo intervenire sin dalla nascita
ma anche quando c'è stato un incrinatura
allora la cura è fondamentale io mi
prendo cura dei pazienti un genitore si
prende cura dei pazienti
platone diceva che un governo dovrebbe
riuscire a prendersi cura dei pazzi del
dei propri cittadini
la cura perché perché la cura uno spazio
questo non lo dico io lo dice jean luc
nancy un filosofo francese lo spazio di
senso condiviso che si è già sullo
sfondo di una coesistenza singolarmente
plurale cioè una singolarità che aperta
alla pluralità del portico l'altro
grazie
[Applauso]